turning now to a story about connecting
in unexpected ways through the wisdom of
a big panda in a tiny dragon the
characters were created by an artist in
wales who uses his real world experience
with despair to craft messages of hope
and forgiveness roxanna siberian shares
his story
yeah done art and writing for
james norbury has been drawing for as
long as he can remember
i never got anywhere with it but he
nearly gave it up it's quite a soul
destroying to keep trying again and
again and again and again and getting
nowhere until he created these two
unlikely friends talking and traveling
together
why a panda and a dragon yeah because
pandas are large and fluffy and cute
and the dragon is
the opposite of what he should be he's
small skinny and
sort of naive
for years the self-taught artist lived
off of around twelve thousand dollars
working odd jobs
i've spent a lot of time
which i guess a lot of people do
thinking that this world is simply not
right for me
but he became inspired volunteering at a
crisis center i felt that i had quite a
lot of
ideas that would help what i found most
appealing was buddhism contained in
there are some extremely powerful ideas
that help you on a on a day-to-day basis
so one day he decided to distill those
ideas into simple yet profound
conversations between big panda and tiny
dragon this garden is beautiful said
tiny dragon big panda nodded and we only
found it because we went the wrong way
so many times they debuted on instagram
around two years ago
i got three likes or something like that
but soon their uplifting messages of
friendship hope and acceptance
reverberated and made their way into a
best-selling book translated into 25
languages
readers send proof of their passion for
his art
and post comments like your creations
hold me up through each day
i had one person once who
said it stopped them taking their own
life
which was
incredible a lot of people say they were
moved to tears and and things and i
think that's because talks to your soul
hopefully and it comes from his
says
what if i meet people who don't like me
or the things i do ask tiny dragon you
must walk your own path said big panda
better to lose them than lose yourself
so
yes yeah
they're very authentic that's why i
think they speak to people
because they come from here you know
they come from your mind and your heart
your soul exactly yeah it's very clear
so
this one says do bad thoughts make me a
bad person no because waves are not the
ocean and thoughts are not the mind
marika fink hangs this illustration
above her desk a print is a lot cheaper
than a shrink i'll tell you what i would
think so it's a lot cheaper but that's
what i mean about his work sometimes you
just look at it and it gives you that
brief moment of yeah right don't don't
dwell on that that's fine yeah i find
that hugely inspiring
oh well that's exactly why i draw them
so that's amazing to hear despite his
global success the 44 year old artist
still lives in the same house with his
five stray cats
how has all this changed your life
remarkably little actually really
what's changed he says is he's learning
to live his dream and the lessons shared
by these two friends
i wish this moment could last forever
said tiny dragon
this moment is all there is it's my old
big panda for cbs mornings roxanna
suberi swansea wales
what a beautiful story what a neat man
and patty our stage manager is saying a
reminder of winnie the pooh and it does
it does have that feeling and he saved a
person's life right many people i bet
because the pandemic you know it's just
so interesting art we've talked about
this before how art music literature
poetry can suit the soul but it's never
been more needed than now and you can
see that when he said he had one like
when he first posted it and now
look at his success i love what was said
and it was in jest but a print is a lot
cheaper than a shrink yeah and like
you're saying vlad oftentimes as humans
we starve ourselves um and our soul
needs food that's right and books are
that art they're food for the soul oh
man yeah i mean that was incredible i
love that and it's a good reminder that
if you're struggling you're not alone
there it is yeah love it panda and
dragon big panda tiny big panda tiny
dragon mama panda sister panda